hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
this right here
is the best samsung phone that i have
ever used
and i think that we're finally ready to
give it our
final review so in this video i'm gonna
be going through
why i think this is literally the best
android phone
that we've seen in years even despite
some of my personal
gripes with it but before i get into
that i do want to mention that i'm
really starting to like this phone
because of the massive variety of issues
that samsung has addressed
and fixed with the s21 ultra compared to
the old
s20 ultra which i really really disliked
i mean i called it a fail and this one
is
definitely not a fail but beyond that
there is one
major downside that is really really
getting to me
but i think that it was necessary and i
think it was worth it samsung decided to
go
all out and they made this phone
extremely
thick look at that it's huge
the camera bump is also massive but
i think that it is worth it because
that's why this is
such a solid phone to me this extra
thickness is
very very annoying especially coming
from my iphone
but if you take a look at all of the
things that the extra thickness improved
it does make it really really worth it
and i'm going to get into that as this
review goes on
but before that i want to start off with
the design
and i think that it's almost perfect the
frame
looks beautiful it's nice and thin this
phone is very solid
the glass everything is really really
nice on the s21 ultra the one thing i
really dislike
is this color this silver color is
horrible
it makes it look so cheap i really don't
like it and i wish we got the black one
instead because that one looks
very very clean and as far as this
camera bump
come on this does not look good it looks
like some kind of weird
cyborg spider it's just massive it's
kind of a mess
and if you compare it to the camera bump
on the note 20 ultra
that one looks premium that one looks
really nice
i don't know why samsung did this but
i'm gonna try and
ignore that because the rest of this
phone is
excellent first of all i want to talk
about this
fingerprint sensor this is
amazing it has much larger surface area
so it becomes extremely reliable i used
to hate
all of the other samsung fingerprint
sensors because you had to have your
thumb
in the perfect spot and it also had
issues with reliability and it wasn't
that fast
this one is improved in basically every
single way
and it's just so easy to use so because
of that new fingerprint sensor
from qualcomm being so good i think that
under display fingerprint sensors are
going to be
huge in the future and there are some
rumors that
the next iphone is actually going to get
the same sensor
because of how good it is now one thing
i really
love about the s21 ultra are the super
thin bezels these bezels are excellent
and they totally kill even the iphone 12
pro max
which got shrunk down bezels but still
these are so much thinner
and samsung keeps doing a great job with
their displays
and of course i really love the whole
punch camera because it's so subtle
sometimes you don't even see it you kind
of ignore it and it just looks really
nice
and i'm kind of blown away by the fact
that samsung was able to fit
speaker grills in between the display
and
the top of the phone i don't know how
they did it but
i am gonna get into the speaker quality
in just a second the display itself
is absolutely phenomenal the quality is
great the brightness is great
everything is good as you'd expect from
samsung they make some of the best
displays out there so i'm very happy
with it
but by far the biggest deal is what
samsung did
with the 120 hertz refresh rate which is
super smooth
but now they fixed one of the major
issues
it now automatically adjusts from
10 hertz up to 120 on the fly so you're
watching a video that's filmed
at 24 fps the display is at 24 hertz
it's
saving battery life and then when you're
navigating through the phone
it's back up to 120 hertz and it feels
super smooth
but samsung did not stop there they
decided
to finally give us full 1440p
display resolution while giving us the
120hz
that is a massive massive deal
in it this just makes the phone in the
display kind of
perfect the reason they didn't do this
before was because of
battery life concerns but with the
automatic refresh rate
that really helps as well as the 5 000
milliamp hour battery
that's why this phone is this thick
but that extra battery size really helps
as well as the new snapdragon 888
processor that new chip that is now
based on a five
nanometer architecture so it's super
efficient as well
and as far as the battery life it has
been great i was playing some games like
call of duty mobile and genshin
impact and the battery life was awesome
it actually beat out the iphone 12 pro
max
by about three percent so it was really
really good in that aspect and i was
very surprised
now in terms of the performance there's
not that big of a jump compared to
the previous chip but what really
matters
is the real world performance while
playing games and impact
i was getting awesome performance and
the main thing was that the display
did not dim the chip was able to cool
itself down while the iphone's display
dimmed even though it has a much more
powerful processor
that is what really matters when it
comes to performance so i am very happy
with the performance and the display
and everything as far as the speakers
they are top notch
as good as they've ever been beating out
the iphone and they just sound
really good with really nice volume as
well
but now i really want to dig deep into
every single camera
that's on the s21 ultra starting with
the selfie cam
which uses a 40 megapixel sensor so you
get
really nice and sharp detail i'm also
very impressed with the regular wide
camera because
you're getting excellent quality and
even when using the pixel binning mode
the photos turn out really great because
now i think
samsung tuned the software and we no
longer have the issues that we used to
have with the s20 ultra and the same
thing for the ultra wide camera
it's always done a great job it turns
out very nice and sharp
there are no issues with that either but
i've got to say that the
telephoto cameras are the star of the
show
because yes we now have two of them and
i think that
that was a genius move by samsung first
off we have the crazy 10x optical zoom
camera
yes that's 10x optical not hybrid
which is what they showed off last year
which was actually
4x optical and the rest was done digital
so that was kind of cheating
but this is actual real 10x optical
because of that you're getting
absolutely insane long range
zoom shots like i mean you can use this
as a telescope
if you're trying to see something super
far away or you're trying to read
something
just pull out your phone zoom in all the
way and you can actually see
way better than what your eyes can see
now the only downside to that 10x zoom
lens is that
the f-stop or the aperture is pretty bad
it's f 4.9 which means it doesn't really
take in that much light so you're
probably going to want to use it in
the sunlight but when it gets darker the
photos start to take on
a lot of noise and that is not good
thankfully there's the other telephoto
zoom camera
which uses a 3x optical zoom range which
is really nice because it's kind of like
a mid-range
and the best part is that the aperture
is much faster
at f 2.4 so you can use it
in kind of lower light situations as
well so i've got to say that finally
with this four rear camera setup i feel
like there are no longer
any compromises and samsung totally
nailed it with this phone and part of
the reason is the new laser auto focus
sensor which is a huge deal because it
finally fixes those auto focus hunting
issues
that we had with the s20 ultra and
because of that
the 8k 24fps video recording mode
is finally usable now that the autofocus
works much better
and the stabilization is good as well
and in every other mode the recording is
great with 4k 60 everything's smooth the
stabilization works on all the lenses
all the settings there are no
compromises with video
now moving on to the specs a little bit
i like that you have the option of
either 12 or 16 gigs of ram
because that is just the sweet spot for
ram and as i've been using this phone i
have not been noticing any apps crashing
so it's just enough and as for the
general specs they are
next level on the s21 ultra you have
bluetooth 5.2
and you have the latest in
groundbreaking
wi-fi 6e which is a big deal
those are specs that the current iphones
do not have
including things like the super fast
charging which the iphones are limited
to like 20 watts and on top of that you
also have new technologies like the
ultra wideband chip
and of course this is the first s-series
phone to get
s-pen support which is a big deal for
those people who used to have to buy the
notes
if they wanted to use the s pen you no
longer have to with this phone
basically what i'm trying to say is that
throughout my experience with this phone
i've realized that this is basically
foolproof
there are no compromises everything is
fixed
and perfected a lot of those issues that
people had
you don't have to worry about anymore
samsung literally
jam-packed everything into this phone
they did have to make it thicker but to
be honest because of everything else
i've got to say that it was worth it and
what really surprises me is that they
actually lowered the price
by 200 compared to the s20 ultra
and on top of that it was actually on
sale 200
less on amazon so if you guys are
interested in this phone
definitely check the amazon price just
in case this is still on sale so with
all of that said i've got to say that i
am
extremely happy with the s21 ultra as
i've been using it over the last couple
of weeks
there is nothing missing there are no
compromises
and because of that i've got to say that
this is the best
flagship smartphone that samsung has
ever made
and i might even say that this is the
best android phone ever made
so i'm extremely happy with this and i
think that if you are going to buy this
phone
you are not going to regret it because
it's future proof
with updated specs and it's got
basically everything that you want
so hopefully you guys enjoyed this
review and if you did go ahead and tap
the like button
and click the circle about to subscribe
definitely check out one of those two
videos right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
you